صحيح انه لم تبدا حرب نوويه او لم يعني
يعلن عن حرب لويه لكن هناك مراقبون
يتحدثون عن كون فعلا دخلنا مرحله هذه
الحرب بشكل متدرج بعد ان كثروا الحديث عن
اسلحه روسيا واوكرانيا التكتيكيه الى اي
مدى يمكن ان يكون هذا الخطر مشابه لحرب
نوويه
من وجهه نظري اعتقد بان كلا الجانبين وبلا
شكل الجانب الاوكراني فاروسيا لديها هذه
الامكانات او الاحتمال النووي وروسيا من
وجهه نظري ليس لديها اي نوال لاستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
لان هذا ما حصل هناك اي استخدام لاسلحه
نوويه
فسوف تحصل كوارث كبيره وسوف تدان روسيا
عالميا
وبسبب ذلك اعتقد بان روسيا
تجنبت حتى استخدام هذا الخطاب لاستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه ولكن من اجل حل هذه
المشكله
فكل حرب يمكن ان تنتهي محادثات السلام
وعلينا ان نفكر بهذه المحادثات